hi there steve kaufman here so
i
want to continue this series on studying
effectively
and whereas in the previous video i
talked about studying effectively in
general
and i'm referring of course to studying
mostly in a school environment or a
university environment
and in the first video i talked about
studying effectively in general in this
video i want to talk about studying
effectively when it comes to learning
languages remember if you enjoy these
videos
please subscribe click on the bell to
get notifications
why is it that so many people struggle
to learn languages at school now
i'm referring to the situation for
example in canada within the english
school system
where
very few
outside of french immersion which is
where english-speaking kids do all of
their schooling in french which is a
great program and perhaps a few hundred
i don't know four or five hundred
thousand kids every year do that but in
the regular french stream very few kids
end up speaking french and that's just a
reality uh i don't know what the
situation is in the us with regard to
foreign languages spanish or in the uk
for that matter
i know that in countries like sweden
and in europe and many countries in
europe kids do learn i'm not sure if
they learn in school or whether they
learn because in the case of sweden they
have
you know
the
television programs english or american
television programs are not dubbed so
they're provided in the
original version so the kids actually
before they even start school they've
heard a lot of english and so they speak
english well
but if i look at the situation in canada
i think there are a number of reasons
why language instruction in school is
not effective
and it kind of goes against some of the
principles of effective study
so first of all the emphasis in schools
despite what people say
is on tests
and it's on testing people for specifics
of grammar
so um i mentioned in the previous video
that in the uk
for their uh
g i can't remember the
gcse or whatever general you know
national tests that they have they were
testing people on specific points of
grammar and this would then determine
whether the learner got their diploma or
didn't get their diploma
issues of grammar that are actually
quite minor they're there yes for
example in french you say
oh
football
or whatever you know
sport for example jouer do piano
but if you got that wrong it would not
inhibit communication if a person
understands french well and is able to
communicate well and makes the odd
mistake like that
it's not that serious because the
majority of students in the school
system end up not being able to speak at
all not being able to understand it all
so what's the possible point of testing
them on these specific points of grammar
all it does is introduce an element of
frustration
sense of failure
plus it's unfair because
as i point out in the earlier video our
brains are not so good at grabbing these
details but our our brains will
gradually develop
a series of patterns around how this
foreign language works and so given
enough exposure to the language
the learners will gradually get better
and if the goal is to be able to use the
language in a practical way to
understand to communicate
meaning
then
really testing people on specific points
of grammar that are taught in grade 4 or
grade 6 or grade 8 and therefore right
away we will test you on whether you
learned it or not
it's actually pointless it's just
building in more resistance to the
language
and again referring to my earlier video
we want learners to explore the language
to cover the same ground
using different materials different
stories different content and of course
the specific grammatical points will
show up in these other you know
contexts and the brain will gradually
start to pick up on them and it's
possible that uh once the brain has had
enough experience with
sort of these aspects of the language
and if the teacher points out that we
say
o and in the case of a sport and jouer
do in the case of musical instrument
that that might
help the learner remember that and then
they might still get it wrong and it
doesn't really matter so
i think the the
the problem in in language instruction
in schools is the teacher decides what
the learner is going to use as a
textbook i've even heard teachers
discourage learners from going
beyond what the teacher is teaching the
teacher wants to control
what the learner is learning the content
that learner is using
again on this
exchange i saw on twitter there's some
discussion in the uk as to which
high-frequency words
learners should have to demonstrate that
they know in order to get their diploma
well the words that the learner knows is
going to reflect what they have read
it's going to reflect what they're
interested in the fact that they don't
know the word now if they got into a
situation where this word appeared
frequently they'd learn it so again i
think that's an unnecessary specific
detail to test people on rather
how do you encourage people and this is
difficult in the case of french in
canada if you live in vancouver there's
not an awful lot of
opportunity to use french but the the
emphasis the focus should be on how do
you get students to graze in the
language to explore in the language
maybe even if you want them to learn
french let them choose the language they
want to learn because if they learn
spanish and they've got some confidence
that they can learn a language assuming
they're more motivated to learn spanish
or chinese or whatever it might be if
they achieve that then it'll be easier
for them to learn french in other words
effective study
is based on the idea that the student is
motivated
and i know that's difficult you've got a
classroom of 25 kids that aren't very
motivated but the challenge has to be
how do we motivate these kids
if
what we do in other words insisting on
certain grammatical
niceties of the language or a certain
set of words that have to be learned and
this will be you know the proof of
whether the student has achieved that
level
if we are building in frustration and
disappointment and uh
you know resistance to the language
we're not helping the situation and the
proof is in the pudding because at least
in the case of canada the vast majority
of students in the english language
stream
graduate after eight or ten years of
french and can't speak french don't
understand french can't speak french i
mean they speak some they might
understand some but essentially they're
not functional in french so
i think that's why
we have to recognize
that that the brain doesn't
respond to this kind of uh you know you
must learn this now and then get the
student to sit down and try and block
learn this thing now
that's not how it works effective study
involves the sort of grazing and also
again in in school instruction the
emphasis is is a on grammar and b on
speaking they have this sort of role
playing in getting the students to speak
they have nothing to say until they
understand well and have you know a
sufficient sort of level of experience
with the language they can't say that
much
if they enjoy doing it fine
but but that should not be in my view
the main
sort of form of instruction emphasis on
being able to say a few things because
once you have
so you have an artificial situation in
the classroom where the student pretends
that they're whatever
you know a store clerk or buying
something
and once they're back in the real world
none of that's going to work for them so
it's far better to focus again as i said
earlier with sort of studying
effectively generally
improve the reading skill and how do you
improve reading skills by reading a lot
so get them to read let them choose what
they want to read it doesn't matter what
they read if they're reading a lot
they're going to be improving their
reading skills and get them to listen
and listen to material that they like
and to voices that they like so you know
the same idea that the most efficient
way to bring
information into the brain to stimulate
the brain to get the brain to form these
new patterns is through a lot of
listening and reading of course when
opportunities are there to speak we
should speak but we shouldn't make that
the sort of
main short-term goal it will eventually
be the long-term goal and once the brain
has enough experience with the language
has developed these patterns to cope
with that language then of course we
want to speak as much as possible but
again
it should be meaningful meaningful
conversation talking about meaningful
things and if we you know once we have
sufficient sufficient base in the
language
we can help the student find people if
not in the classroom even online that
they can talk to and talk in a
meaningful way not in a sort of
role-playing way so
there you have it my view on why
language instruction in the schools is
not effective at least
in
english speaking canada and i have the
impression from this exchange i saw on
twitter there are serious problems in
the uk as well and if we look at the
results in terms of how many people
speak a foreign language in those
countries
hasn't been very effective
so thank you for listening bye for now